le théâtre de boulevard se porte bien à
preuve cette pièce de shérif mari au
théâtre saint-georges qui poursuit sa
deuxième année avec succès principaux
interprètes micheline boudet qui a
tornade jean jacques dufour a rencontré
ce dernier deux mots c'est l'histoire
d'un monsieur qui a le démon de midi et
alors sa femme et son fils vont essayer
de le récupérer sans qu'il s'en
aperçoive
déjà qu'ils vont le charrier d'où le
titre de charry marine
voilà d'accord est ce que vous pouvez
nous dire un peu tôt de la situation
dans le théâtre de boulevard aujourd'hui
est ce que ça marche toujours bien ce
que les spectateurs viennent le tient de
bouloire marche très bien en face qu'on
appelle le tir des boulevards ce que moi
j'appelle sur le théâtre de
divertissement
elle marche très bien où les gens
habitent se divertir se changer les
idées
il fonctionne très très bien la preuve
tous les nouveaux spectacles qui sont
sortis moi j'ai l'impression que les
auteurs sont peut être un peu moins bon
qu'au début du siècle à vous voulez
parler de labiche feydeau et tout ça
c'est certain mais en nous avons aussi
solaire ou simplement des gens comme ça
qui travaille pour le boulevard très
très bien et puis avec bruno ce qui
restera sûrement à l'auteur comme la
biche ou feydeau vraiment un extrait de
la pièce ça se passe à quel moment ça se
passe pratiquement vers la fin de la
pièce c'est à dire que ils me font
croire que mon fils a eu un accident de
moto épouvantable pour me ramener un peu
l'endroit chemin vous faire prendre
conscience des réalités
on va regarder ces extraits du sud
michèle dionne cambrioler avec sa moto
cherchez un puzzle bien là moi aussi
dieu
madame vous savez bien que du bidon
heureusement c'est à quoi tomber raide
nord formidable j'ai marché
c'est ça que vous appelez déménagement
et mon mari vous auriez pu le tuer je
vous aime bien dit comprendre quelque
chose à lausanne
elles ont autant de gerland c'est un
contenant de voix que ce soit je vais
revenir pensez-vous maladroit comme il y
en a pour dix minutes vraiment une
grande artiste comme moi d'ici altitude
de première serait pas aussi bien
juste un petit peu tour d'histoire c'est
le choc
seul
mais si j'avais bien d'autres
il en parlait mais on va pas qu'est ce
qui s'est passé